This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. About a year ago, we released an episode in which I interviewed the author of Cassia St. Clair about her book The Secret Lives of Color. It was a conversation about the history and origins of different colors throughout human existence. And during our talk, Cassia and I covered everything from a type of purple that squeezed from seasnails to a shade of green that could literally kill you. a type of purple that's squeezed from seasnails to a shade of green that could literally kill you. But there was one pigment in particular from that episode that one of our producers here at Nine N.I.P.I. hasn't been able to stop thinking about.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。大约一年前，我们发布了一期节目，采访了《色彩的秘密生活》一书的作者卡西亚·圣克莱尔。那是一场关于人类历史上各种颜色起源的对话。在交谈中，卡西亚和我聊到了各种事物，从从海螺中挤出的紫色，到一种真的能让你丧命的绿色。但那期节目中有一种特殊的颜料，让我们“99%隐形”的一位制作人一直念念不忘。
Because it's bonkers. Producer Vivian Le. It's called Vanta Black. And it's a pigment that reaches the level of darkness that's so intense, it's kind of upsetting. It's so black, it's like looking at a hole cut out of the universe. It's so black, it's like looking at a portal into another dimension of nothingness. It's so black that if you've stared it long enough, you'll see your own death.
因为它太疯狂了。制作人薇薇安·勒。它叫“梵塔黑”（Vanta Black）。这是一种深邃到令人不安的颜料。它黑得就像在宇宙中挖了一个洞。它黑得就像在凝视通往虚无维度的入口。它黑得如果你盯着它看太久，你甚至会看到自己的死亡。
I can keep going. These metaphors are crummy, but it's like this philosophical abyss, your eyes just fall into it. This is Adam Rogers. I'm a journalist. I'm a writer at Wired, and I write books sometimes too. Rogers has written about Vandablack for Wired because when anyone sees it, not just Vivian, they think it's bonkers. It makes you rethink what black means.
我还能继续说下去。这些比喻虽然蹩脚，但它就像一个哲学深渊，你的眼睛会不由自主地陷进去。这是亚当·罗杰斯。我是一名记者。我是《连线》杂志的撰稿人，有时也写书。罗杰斯曾为《连线》撰写过关于梵塔黑的文章，因为当任何人——不仅仅是薇薇安——看到它时，都会觉得它太疯狂了。它让你重新思考“黑色”的含义。
Vandablack is striking when you look at it, even when you look at a picture of it, because it looks not like something is colored black. It looks like unabsence. Vanta black swallows nearly all visible light and gives back no reflection. So every contour or crease of whatever it's applied to disappears. It has this odd effect of making something look too dimensional, well at the same time as if you could fall right through it. It has the same feeling looking at it as a color that looking over the edge of a building
当你看着梵塔黑时，即使只是看它的照片，也会感到震撼，因为它看起来不像是一种被染成黑色的东西。它看起来像是“非存在”。梵塔黑几乎吸收了所有可见光，且没有任何反射。因此，无论它涂在什么物体上，所有的轮廓或褶皱都会消失。它有一种奇怪的效果，让物体看起来既像失去了维度，又像是一个你可以直接坠入的深渊。看着它，就像站在建筑物边缘往下看一样。
or something does. You actually do feel kind of a physiological response. That does not look right. That looks unreal. It looks unreal. Vanta Black was created by the tech industry for the tech industry, but this strange dark material would actually go on to turn the art world on its head. There are black pigments out there, and then there are super black pigments that are so dark they need to be created in a laboratory. These super blacks reach such extreme levels of darkness because they're made up of something called carbon nanotubes, or CNTs. Carbon nanotubes are pretty much exactly what they sound like. Teeny, tiny microscopic tubes comprise of carbon atoms just a few nanometers wide. For reference, a single human hair is about 80 to 100,000 nanometers wide.
或者类似的感觉。你确实会产生一种生理反应。那看起来不对劲。那看起来很不真实。它看起来很不真实。梵塔黑是由科技行业为科技行业创造的，但这种奇异的黑色材料最终却颠覆了艺术界。市面上有很多黑色颜料，但还有一种“超黑”颜料，它们黑到必须在实验室里制造出来。这些超黑材料之所以能达到如此极端的黑暗程度，是因为它们由一种叫做“碳纳米管”（CNTs）的物质组成。碳纳米管听起来是什么样，基本就是什么样。它们是微小的、由碳原子组成的管子，宽度仅有几纳米。作为参考，一根人类头发的宽度大约是8万到10万纳米。
CNT materials are made up of forests of these microscopic carbon tubes. I'd say it's like a field of grass, okay, and the grass is a carbon anotube and about 1,6,000 to thickness of your hair, and there's about a billion of them per square centimeter. This is Ben Jensen, the founder and CTO of Surinano Systems, which specializes in carbon nanotube technology. He's the kind of person who, even as a kid, you'd expect to become the founder and CTO of a carbon nanotube technology company. When I went through school, I spent my time trying to make gunpowder type rockets, and
碳纳米管材料是由这些微小碳管组成的“森林”。我想说它就像一片草地，好吧，每一根“草”都是一个碳纳米管，大约是你头发厚度的六万分之一，每平方厘米大约有十亿根。这是本·詹森，Surrey NanoSystems公司的创始人兼首席技术官，该公司专门从事碳纳米管技术。他就是那种即使在小时候，你也会预料到他未来会成为碳纳米管技术公司创始人兼首席技术官的人。当我上学时，我花时间尝试制造火药火箭，
then I kind of went to develop liquid propellant systems that were rather dangerous and used to go bang and kind of not very safe. Back then, people didn't really care that much about safety and they go, yeah, yeah, this sounds like a really cool idea. Kids, this is not a really cool idea. Jensen began working in the nanomaterials field in 2004. Back then, CNTs had a lot of promise in this based industry because super black coatings could be really useful inside of satellites, telescopes, and optical imaging technology.
然后我开始开发液体推进系统，那些系统相当危险，经常会爆炸，不太安全。那时候，人们对安全并不太在意，他们会说：“是啊，是啊，这听起来是个很酷的主意。”孩子们，这可不是什么好主意。詹森于2004年开始从事纳米材料领域的工作。当时，碳纳米管在航天工业中非常有前景，因为超黑涂层在卫星、望远镜和光学成像技术中非常有用。
But carbon nanotube technology wasn't quite where it needed to be yet. C&T's weren't like paint. They had to be grown onto a surface in a special type of reactor at an absurdly high temperature. High enough to destroy most of the things you might want to grow them on. Jensen and his team worked on it for years and finally managed to develop a new reactor that allowed them to grow CNTs at a much lower temperature. And in doing so, they had one unexpected but delightful side effect.
但碳纳米管技术当时还不够成熟。碳纳米管不像油漆。它们必须在特殊的反应器中，以极高的温度生长在表面上。这个温度高到足以摧毁大多数你想在其上生长碳纳米管的物体。詹森和他的团队研究了多年，终于开发出一种新的反应器，使他们能够在低得多的温度下生长碳纳米管。在这样做的过程中，他们得到了一个意想不到但令人惊喜的副作用。
They made it blacker. One day we got some data back and they said, do you realize what you've done? You've grown this material and it's got almost unmeasurably low reflectance and I was okay. What does that mean? It meant that sereninous systems had created the darkest substance on earth a material that absorbed 99.965 percent of light He couldn't tell from the numbers, but Jensen knew the CNT was really special after one of his researchers showed him a sample.
他们让它变得更黑了。有一天，我们得到了一些数据，他们问：“你意识到你做了什么吗？你生长出的这种材料，其反射率低到几乎无法测量。”我说：“好吧，那意味着什么？”这意味着Surrey NanoSystems创造了地球上最黑的物质，一种吸收了99.965%光线的材料。他无法从数字中看出端倪，但在他的一位研究员向他展示样本后，詹森知道这种碳纳米管真的很特别。
And he said, look, and I'm like, okay, what am I looking at? It just looks black. And he said, no, no, look. And I'm putting my face right up beside it, and the guy is looking and laughing at me. And I'm going, hey, I just looks black. And then he did something that just told me we'd nailed it. He took an object off the surface that was three-dimensional, so I could then see it. Before no matter how close I'd put my eyes to it, I couldn't tell there was anything there. It was just flat. Vanta Black was so dark that it almost felt like it defied the laws of physics. We weren't looking to create the world's blackest material. That wasn't our thing.
他说：“看。”我心想：“好吧，我在看什么？它看起来只是黑色的。”他说：“不，不，再看。”我把脸凑到它旁边，那家伙看着我笑。我说：“嘿，它看起来就是黑色的。”然后他做了一件事，让我确信我们成功了。他从表面拿走了一个三维物体，我这才看出来。在那之前，无论我把眼睛凑得有多近，我都看不出上面有什么东西。它看起来就是平的。梵塔黑太黑了，以至于感觉它几乎违背了物理定律。我们并不是为了创造世界上最黑的材料，那不是我们的目标。
Jensen and his team decided to give this new flashy CNT of flashy name, Vanta Black. Which stands for vertically aligned nano tube array, black. As black as Vanta Black was, serenano systems still saw it as a niche material. So when they launched their product at the Farmboro Air Show in 2014, they saw themselves as small fry.
詹森和他的团队决定给这种新的碳纳米管起一个响亮的名字：Vanta Black。它代表“垂直排列纳米管阵列”（Vertically Aligned Nano Tube Array）黑色。尽管梵塔黑非常黑，但Surrey NanoSystems仍然将其视为一种小众材料。因此，当他们在2014年法恩伯勒航展上推出产品时，他们认为自己只是小角色。
Farmboro is a big deal in the aerospace industry. Surrey Nano systems was presenting their Nano material at the same event as the Boeing Dreamliner, military jets, and a paragliding car. So Jensen wasn't expecting to make much of a splash. But that's not what actually happened. It was just surreal. We had camera crews from literally all the major networks there filming, looking at these materials, because no one had ever seen anything demonstrated like this before. People were freaking out over Vanta Black.
法恩伯勒航展在航空航天业地位很高。Surrey NanoSystems在波音梦幻客机、军用喷气式飞机和滑翔车所在的同一活动中展示他们的纳米材料。所以詹森没指望能引起多大轰动。但事实并非如此。这简直太超现实了。我们有来自所有主流电视网的摄制组在那里拍摄，观察这些材料，因为以前从未有人见过这样的演示。人们对梵塔黑感到疯狂。
We just didn't expect it, and my scientist was like, well, it's just black. Why are we getting all these people going crazy about it? over Vanta Black. We just didn't expect it, and my scientist was like, well, it's just black. Why are we getting all these people going crazy about it? People were amazed by the depth of darkness achieved by Vanta Black and wanted to know more. Soon enough, serenino systems was receiving all sorts of requests from people who wanted a piece of it. You've got people wanting to coat their cars in it.
我们完全没料到，我的科学家说：“好吧，它只是黑色的。为什么这些人会为它疯狂？”人们对梵塔黑所达到的黑暗深度感到惊叹，并想了解更多。很快，Surrey NanoSystems收到了各种各样的人发来的请求，他们都想分一杯羹。有人想用它涂满自己的汽车。
People wanting to coat dice in it, coat their bodies in it. We had a very well-known YouTube that spent quite a while asking us saying can we please eat it live on YouTube. Aside from that time-part eating f***ing idiot, what really caught Jensen's attention was the amount of interest that came from another field in desperate need of a super black pigment, the art world. In those first couple of weeks alone, Serenano systems received over 400 inquiries
有人想用它涂满骰子，涂满自己的身体。我们有一位非常有名的YouTube博主花了很长时间问我们，能不能请我们在YouTube直播中吃掉它。除了那个想吃掉它的白痴之外，真正引起詹森注意的是来自另一个急需超黑颜料的领域——艺术界——的浓厚兴趣。仅在最初的几周内，Surrey NanoSystems就收到了超过400份咨询。
from artists wanting to use it in their work. The number of people in the art world that wanted to use it, that was absolutely quite a crazy time, actually, because we're a company that's set up to do engineering and space, not a company that's set up to create products for artists to use. Working with artists was just not something Surin Anosystems was equipped to do, because Vant Black was incredibly hard to work with. Sure, they could grow it at a much lower temperature than before, but that was still about 430 degrees centigrade. C&T's were also really delicate and could scrape off easily.
来自想要在作品中使用它的艺术家。艺术界想要使用它的人数之多，那段时间确实非常疯狂，因为我们是一家为工程和航天而设立的公司，而不是一家为艺术家创造产品的公司。与艺术家合作并不是Surrey NanoSystems具备的能力，因为梵塔黑非常难处理。当然，他们可以在比以前低得多的温度下生长它，但那仍然需要大约430摄氏度。碳纳米管也非常脆弱，很容易被刮掉。
But most importantly, any collaboration with artists would take up time and tech resources because anything coated with band-a-black would have to be grown in Serene Anosystems reactors. Just wasn't a practical proposition for the company. That said, Anish is an incredibly charismatic chap with an amazing vision and his life's work has just been phenomenal. Anish, as in Anish Kapoor, who if you haven't heard of him before, is very famous. So Anish Kapoor for decades has been one of the premier contemporary artists working today. This is Adam Rogers again. He's the kind of person who will do like a whole gallery
但最重要的是，与艺术家的任何合作都会占用时间和技术资源，因为任何涂有梵塔黑的东西都必须在Surrey NanoSystems的反应器中生长。这对公司来说并不是一个实际的提议。话虽如此，阿尼什（Anish）是一个非常有魅力的人，有着惊人的愿景，他一生的作品都非常出色。阿尼什，指的是阿尼什·卡普尔（Anish Kapoor），如果你以前没听说过他，他非常出名。所以，几十年来，阿尼什·卡普尔一直是当今最顶尖的当代艺术家之一。这是亚当·罗杰斯。他就是那种会包下整个泰特现代美术馆的人。
takeover of the tape modern. You know, he's a really big deal. We should know here that Anishka War did not respond to an interview request for this story, but he's probably best known for creating Chicago's iconic Cloud Gate sculpture, also known as the Bean, and he has been knighted by Queen Elizabeth for his contributions to visual arts.
你知道，他是个大人物。我们应该在这里说明，阿尼什·卡普尔没有回应关于这个故事的采访请求，但他最出名的作品可能是芝加哥标志性的“云门”雕塑，也被称为“豆子”，他因对视觉艺术的贡献而被伊丽莎白女王封为爵士。
And when Vance of Black debuted, he wanted it. So he reached out to Surinano Systems and invited Jensen to check out his studio. I walked into his studio and I was literally speechless at what I saw. Given his body of work, Kapoor seemed uniquely suited for this material. suited for this material. There is in a way a constant continuous process that gives up the same questions. This is Anish Kapoor in a video he released about one of his pieces titled Disension. So those questions are for me, you know, the void object or the non-object. Many questions about colour, questions about space and time, because I really do believe that for there to be new objects, there has to be new space.
当梵塔黑首次亮相时，他想要它。于是他联系了Surrey NanoSystems，并邀请詹森去参观他的工作室。我走进他的工作室，看到的东西让我简直说不出话来。考虑到他的作品集，卡普尔似乎非常适合这种材料。在某种程度上，有一个持续的过程提出了同样的问题。这是阿尼什·卡普尔在他发布的一段关于他作品《下降》（Descension）的视频中所说的。所以对我来说，这些问题是，你知道，虚空物体或非物体。关于颜色、空间和时间的许多问题，因为我真的相信，要产生新的物体，就必须有新的空间。
Kapoor has a fascination with black's capacity to make something both exist and not exist at the same time. His work, a lot of it, deals with voids, deals with color blocks and voids, tries to understand the relationship between color and space. One art installation titled Descent in Delimbo is just a giant black hole in the ground that looks like it plummets into oblivion. There was a circle on the floor that was just blacker than black could possibly be.
卡普尔对黑色使某物同时存在又不存在的能力着迷。他的许多作品都涉及虚空，涉及色块和虚空，试图理解颜色与空间之间的关系。一个名为《下降到地狱》（Descent into Limbo）的艺术装置，只是地面上的一个巨大的黑洞，看起来像是坠入了遗忘。地板上有一个圆圈，黑得比黑还要黑。
A couple of years ago, somebody actually fell into it. Now to the Italian man who found out the hard way that a very realistic looking painting of a black hole was in fact an actual black hole. Fortunately, the man who tested the art out is going to be okay. He's now at home, recovering from a back injury. Serena ecosystems couldn't work
几年前，有人真的掉进去了。现在，那位意大利人以惨痛的方式发现，一幅非常逼真的黑洞画作实际上是一个真正的黑洞。幸运的是，那位测试艺术品的人会没事的。他现在在家中，正在从背部受伤中恢复。Surrey NanoSystems无法与400位不同的艺术家合作，但他们可以与一位合作。卡普尔是完美的选择。他们与卡普尔签署了一份合同，规定他将是第一个也是唯一一个可以使用梵塔黑的艺术家。Surrey NanoSystems已经与国防和航天行业的承包商签订了各种独家许可协议。
with 400 different artists, but they could work with one. Kapoor was the perfect choice. They signed a contract with Kapoor, stating he would be the first and only artist who would get to work with Vanta Black. Serena ecosystems already had all sorts of exclusive licenses with contractors in the defense and space industries.
所以他们认为艺术家的许可协议不会有什么不同。Surrey NanoSystems认为这笔交易与他们与任何其他想要使用他们制造的东西（世界上没有其他人能制造的东西）的人所做的交易是一样的，这并非不可想象。这并不疯狂，但它确实产生了后果。这在艺术界引起了轰动。我们原本预计，当我们宣布它是独家时，它会限制我们收到的请求数量。
So they figured an artist license wouldn't be that different. It's not implausible that Serene nanosystems thought that the deal was the same as any other deal that they would make with anybody else who wanted to use one of the things that they made, that nobody else in the world could make. That's not crazy, but it did have consequences. with anybody else who wanted to use one of the things that they made, that nobody else in the world could make. That's not crazy, but it did have consequences. Consequences that rocked the art world. We had expected when we announced it was exclusive, that it would limit the amount of requests we were getting
因为公司内部的行政人员简直被艺术界的请求轰炸和压垮了。在宣布这种关系后，这种情况真的发生了吗？遗憾的是没有。再一次，人们对梵塔黑感到疯狂，但这次是因为非常不同的原因。起初，人们认为阿尼什·卡普尔以某种方式获得了黑色这种颜色的独家许可，这显然是不真实的。这引发了一场仇恨风暴，我回想起那段时间，我们收到了
because the administration staff within the company was simply bombarded and overloaded with requests from the art world. Did that actually happen after this relationship was announced? Sadly not. Once again, people were freaking out over Vanta Black, but for very different reason this time. At first, people thought that somehow Anishikapur had the exclusive license to the color black, which was obviously not true. And that created a far storm of hatred, and I think back to that time we were getting
仇恨邮件、死亡威胁，各种疯狂的东西。你知道互联网是什么样的。梵塔黑是一种纳米技术，只能使用Surrey NanoSystems的专有反应器和受过培训的技术人员才能实现。它不是一种颜色，它是一种技术。他们没有为一种吸收99.95%光线的黑色申请专利。他们为一种吸收99.95%光线的独特工艺和材料申请了专利。尽管如此，许多人认为技术并不重要。所以我们谈论的是对“无光”的所有权。
hate mail, death threats, all kinds of crazy stuff. You know what the internet's like. Vanta Black is a nanotechnology that can only be achieved using serene nanosystems, proprietary reactor and trained technicians. It is not a color, it's a technology. They didn't patent a shade of black that absorbs 99.95% of light. They patented a unique process and material that absorbed 99.95% of light. Still, a lot of people thought that technology was beside the point. So we're talking about ownership of no light.
那么一个人怎么能拥有“无光”呢？这是斯图尔特·森普尔（Stuart Semple），一位居住在英国伯恩茅斯的艺术家。我很快就理解了使用这种材料有多复杂，但这并没有改变我对这种达成的独家安排的看法。起初，斯图尔特在第一次听说梵塔黑时非常兴奋，尽管他不确定自己会用它做什么。我当时并没有真正考虑我会如何使用它。我的意思是，我最初只是对这种材料本身感到敬畏。
So how can someone own no light? This is Stuart's simple and artist based in Bournemouth in the UK. I understood quite quickly how elaborate it was to use the stuff, but that didn't change how I felt about this exclusive arrangement that had hatched. Initially, Stuart was really excited when he first heard about Vanta Black, even though he wasn't sure what he would make with it. I wasn't really thinking about how I'd use it. I mean, I was initially just in awe at the stuff itself.
我并没有什么想法，因为当我还没来得及构思出想法时，结果发现阿尼什·卡普尔拥有了它的权利以及其他一切。斯图尔特实际上并不责怪Surrey NanoSystems选择与阿尼什·卡普尔合作。他们来自科技界，有着完全不同的思维方式。他沮丧的对象是阿尼什·卡普尔。斯图尔特认为，从道德上讲，作为一名艺术家，卡普尔应该知道，试图将梵塔黑据为己有是不对的。从历史上看，现在也是如此，艺术的很大一部分一直依赖于新技术。
I hadn't really got ideas because by the time I'd had a chance to hatch an idea for it, it turned out that Inesh Kapoor had the rights to it and everything else. Stuart actually doesn't blame Serenano systems for choosing to work with Anishikapur. They came from the world of tech and had a completely different mindset. The object of his frustration was Anishikapur. Stuart thinks morally, as an artist, Kapur should have known better than to try to keep Vanta Black exclusively for himself. Historically and presently, so much of art has been dependent on new technology.
从油画颜料到摄影，再到视频，艺术随着技术上的可能性而进化。因此，这种新材料被故意对艺术界的其他人隐瞒，激怒了很多人，包括斯图尔特·森普尔。这简直充满了艺术界的精英主义，以及如果你有钱有地位，就有能力支配事物的味道。尽管Surrey NanoSystems的本·詹森很快指出，艺术家对技术进行保护在艺术界并不是什么新鲜事。
From oil paints, to photography, to video, art evolves with whatever is technologically possible. So the fact that this new material was purposefully being withheld from the rest of the artistic community ruffled a lot of feathers, including storage symbols. It just smacked of complete art world elitism and the power to dominate things if you've got money and and stature. Although Ben Jensen from Serenano Systems is quick to point out that artists being protective of technology isn't actually a new thing in the art world.
艺术家自文艺复兴以来就一直在创造自己的油画颜料，他们没有义务与竞争对手分享他们的材料。今天，人们觉得，如果某样东西存在，他们就自动拥有权利。所以因为我们创造了这种材料，每个人都自动拥有权利，现实是世界从来都不是那样的。你回到特纳（Turner）创造他的黑色时，你走到他面前说：“嘿，你创造了一种惊人的黑色，我想要它。”
Artists have been creating their own oil paints since the Renaissance, and they were under no artists being protective of technology isn't actually a new thing in the art world. Artists have been creating their own oil paint since the Renaissance, and they were under no obligation to share their material with their competitors. Today, people feel, if something exists, they have an automatic right to it. So because we created this material, everybody has an automatic right to it, the reality is the world has never been like that. You go back to when Turner was creating his blacks and you go up to him and say, hey, you created an amazing black eye wanted it.
你会因为艺术界的原因而被嘲笑。但森普尔以不同的方式看待它。无论文艺复兴时期的艺术家做了什么，他都认为分享知识和技术才能推动艺术界向前发展。这就是为什么他实际上感到有点虚伪。斯图尔特多年来一直在混合自己的颜料和染料用于自己的艺术作品，他意识到他并没有践行他所宣扬的“分享”。我并不比他好，因为我一直在制作这些很棒的颜色，却只是
You would have been laughed out of the artsy. But simple sees it a different way. Regardless of what Renaissance artists did, he believes that sharing knowledge and technology can only move the arts community forward. Which is why he actually felt a little hypocritical. Stort had been mixing his own paints and pigments for years to use in his own artwork, and he realized he wasn't practicing what he preached, sharing. I was no better than him because I'd been making these awesome colors and just using them
留给自己用。我一直在囤积它们用于我自己的工作。我没有分享它们。斯图尔特有一堆他自己创造的颜料。最绿的绿色，最粉的粉色，最闪的闪粉，你懂的。他想到他可以一箭双雕。他可以与他的艺术同行分享他的颜色，并对阿尼什·卡普尔对梵塔黑的独家许可开个小玩笑。所以我心想，我要做的是把我自己制作的“最粉的粉色”分享给全世界，
for myself. I'd been hoarding them for my own work. I wasn't sharing them. Stort had a bunch of pigments that he created himself. The green is green, the pinkest pink, the glitteriest glitter, you get the idea. And it occurred to him that he could kill two birds with one stone. He could share his colors with his artistic peers and poke a little fun at a niche capore's exclusive license to Vanta Black. So I thought what I'll do is I'll share my pinkist pink that I made with the whole world
并把它作为一个笑话放在互联网上，作为一件行为艺术作品，如果你愿意的话，利用互联网作为辩论和对话的空间。有一个警告：世界上每个人都可以使用这种新颜色，除了阿尼什·卡普尔。我会禁止阿尼什·卡普尔使用我的粉色。斯图尔特在他的网站上出售他的颜色之一——“最粉的粉色”，并附带了一份非常具体的购买协议。所以要购买“最粉的粉色”，
and put it on the internet as a joke as a piece of performance art if you like to use the internet as a space for debate and dialogue. With one caveat, everyone in the world could use this new color except an Iskapur. I would ban Anish Kapoor from using my pink. Stewart put one of his colors, the pinkest pink, up for sale on his website with a very specific purchasing agreement. So to buy the pinkest pink,
当你把它加入购物车时，你必须同意网站上的法律条款和条件。它们是：你不是阿尼什·卡普尔，你与阿尼什·卡普尔没有任何关联，据你所知、所信，这种颜料不会落入阿尼什·卡普尔手中。
you have to agree to legal terms and conditions on the website when you add it to your car. And they are that you're not an Ish Kapoor, you're in no way associated, you're affiliated to an Ish Kapoor, and the best of your knowledge, information, and belief, the paint won't make its way into the hands of anish Kapoor.
这一举动既是笑话，也是行为艺术。他以为他的几个朋友会买一些，他们会对此大笑一场。但他最终卖出了数万罐“最粉的粉色”，每一罐都是对卡普尔的一个小小的中指。事情从那里迅速升级。卡普尔回来后，发布了一张他对着镜头竖中指的照片，他的
The move was part joke, part performance art. He figured a few of his friends would buy some and they'd have a good laugh about it. But he ended up selling tens of thousands of jars of the pinkest pink, each one a tiny middle finger to Kapoor. And things escalated quickly from there. Kapoor comes back, posts a picture of him giving the middle finger to the camera with his
手指涂上了这种粉色，森普尔的粉色。亚当·罗杰斯再次登场。阿尼什·卡普尔以某种方式绕过了斯图尔特的铁律用户协议，并在他的Instagram账户上发布了一张他真正的中指涂着“最粉的粉色”的照片。所以这就像青少年的打架，对吧？就像他们在社交媒体上打架一样。我当时没觉得那真的是阿尼什·卡普尔，
finger coated in this pink, in Samples pink. Adam Rogers again. Anish Kapoor had somehow managed to get around Stewart's Ironclad user agreement and posted a picture to his Instagram account of his actual middle finger covered in the pinkest pink. So this is like a teenager's fighting, right? Like they're having a fight on social media. I didn't think it was actually anish kupou,
所以我以为只是有人在开玩笑。但当我意识到那是他时，我心想：“哦，天哪，这真的很糟糕。”这很糟糕，但对斯图尔特来说也算是一件好事。他让业内最著名的艺术家之一公开对他竖中指。现在他有了互联网的支持。艺术界的其他人，在成千上万的评论中，都在说：
so I just thought it was someone having a joke. But then when I realized it was him, I was like, oh my God, that's really, really bad. It was bad, but it was also kind of good for Stuart. He got one of the most prominent artists in the industry to publicly flip him the bird. And now he had the internet on his side. The rest of the artistic community in thousands and thousands of comments was like,
“如果你回击，伙计。”评论者涌向阿尼什·卡普尔的Instagram帖子，告诉他要加上“分享黑色”（#ShareTheBlack）的标签。斯图尔特突然发现自己身后有一支开源艺术捍卫者大军，他准备发起全面攻击。斯图尔特捕捉到了那种氛围，但他心想：“好吧，如果非要这样，那我就制造一种更好的黑色。”所以他决定在卡普尔自己的游戏中击败他，
if you write back, buddy. Commenters piled on Nuanish Kapoor's Instagram post, telling him to hashtag Share the Black. Stewart suddenly found himself with an army of open-source art defenders behind him, and he was right at a mount a full-scale attack. And Stort, it's like captured that vibe, but he thought, well, okay, if that's the way it's gonna be, I'm gonna make a better black. So we decided to beat Kapoor at his own game
创造一种可以与梵塔黑媲美的超黑颜料。这花费了多年的开发和多次迭代，以及整个众包艺术家反馈社区的努力，才开发出他称之为“Black 3.0”的配方。在化妆品行业成长过程中，我们使用了所谓的“消光剂”。所以我们借用了其中的一些技术，然后我们重新配制了粘合剂，使其非常开放
and create a super black paint that could rival Vanta Black. It took years of development and multiple iterations and entire community of crowdsourced artist feedback to develop the formula for something that he calls Black3. Growing in the cosmetics industry, we used what we call mattifiers. So we borrowed some of that technology and then we reformulated the binder to make it really open
而且非常白。这样我们就可以在里面塞入大量的黑色颜料，这使得它变得非常超黑，几乎像天鹅绒一样。Black 3.0没有梵塔黑吸收的光线多，但它仍然非常黑。你可以想象在正义联盟里站在超人旁边是什么感觉。
and really white. So we could cram loads later this black pigment in there, which makes this really super black, almost like Valver thing. Black 3 doesn't trap as much light as Vanta Black, but it's still pretty dark. You can imagine what it's like in the justice league to stand next to Super Red.
哦，不，你没有那么多。但我仍然有一些超红。你仍然非常强大。是的，你仍然非常强大，没错。Black 3.0就像海王。没关系。我有一些仍然……你仍然非常强大。是的，你仍然非常强大，没错。Black 3.0就像海王。没关系。斯图尔特确保它是一种丙烯颜料，因为任何画家都能轻松使用它。
Oh, no, you don't have that many. But I have some Super Redress still. You're still very strong. Yeah, you're still very strong, exactly. Black 3 is like Aquaman. It's fine. I have some superpowers that still... You're still very strong. Yeah, you're still very strong, exactly. Black 3 is like Aquaman. It's fine. Stuart made sure it was an acrylic paint because any painter would be able to easily work with it.
它也很实惠，所以艺术家们真的买得起。最后……如果你是阿尼什·卡普尔，如果你与阿尼什·卡普尔有关联，或者据你所知、所信，它会落入阿尼什·卡普尔手中，你就不能购买Black 3.0。阿尼什·卡普尔短期内不会用Black 3.0作画，但事实证明，斯图尔特·森普尔也不会。
It's also affordable so that artists can actually buy it. And lastly... You can't buy Black 3 if you're an Isch Kapoor, if you're associated with an Isch Kapoor, or to the best of your knowledge, information, belief it's going to make it's way into the hands of an Isch Kapoor, if you're associated with Anish Kapoor, or to the best of your knowledge information and belief it's going to make it's way into the hands of Anish Kapoor. Anish Kapoor wouldn't be painting with black three anytime soon, but it turns out neither woods do or simple.
你知道，它对我的作品来说太黑了。我不能用它。它太黑了。一旦你把它涂在画上，它就会支配一切。在所有的争斗、研发和创造世界上最黑的黑色之一所付出的艰苦努力之后，斯图尔特并没有使用它。奇怪的是，最初引发这场争议的阿尼什·卡普尔也没有怎么使用他那最黑的黑色。几年前，他发布了一款限量版9.8万美元的梵塔黑手表，但仅此而已。
Do you know it's too black for my work. I can't use it. It's too black. The minute you put it on a painting, it just dominates everything. After all the feuding, research and development and sheer painstaking work that went into creating one of the world's blackest blacks, Stewart doesn't use it. And oddly enough, Anishikapur, the person who set off this whole controversy in the first place, hasn't used his blackest black very much either. A few years back, he released a limited edition $98,000 Vanta Black watch, but that's about it.
森普尔和卡普尔都没有什么理由拥有世界上最黑的颜料，但有一位艺术家确实有。喂？你好，我是德穆特（Demote）。是我，你好，很高兴和你交谈。德穆特·斯特里布（Demote Strib）在艺术与科学的交叉领域工作。最近，她凭空拿出了一种黑色颜料，使卡普尔和森普尔之间的整个
Neither simple nor capore had much use in having the darkest pigment in the world, but there was one artist who actually did. Hello? Hi, this is Demote. That's me, hello, so nice to talk to you. Demote Strib works at the intersection of art and science. And recently, she came out of nowhere with a black pigment that rendered the entire
争斗变得毫无意义。最棒的是，她甚至不是故意的。在这种环境下，我的艺术作品确实引发了一项科学发现，这在当今时代是不寻常的。通常艺术作品不会引发科学论文，但在这种情况下，它确实来自艺术界，我认为这真的很酷。2019年，斯特里布发布了一件名为《虚荣的救赎》（The Redemption of Vanity）的作品，她用一种与麻省理工学院Next Lab合作开发的新型纳米管材料涂覆了一颗200万美元的钻石。这是对物质价值的批判，因为钻石的价值在视觉上被降低为零。
feud between Kapoor and Semple pretty much meaningless. And the best part is, she didn't even mean to. My artwork in this setting really triggered a scientific discovery, which is unusual in these times. Usually artistic work would not trigger a scientific paper, but in this case it was, it really came out of the arts and I thought this was really cool. In 2019, Stree released a work called The Redemption of Vanity, in which she coded a $2 million dollar in a new nanotube material developed with MIT's next lab. It's a critique of material value because the diamond's value is visually speaking, reduced to nothing.
钻石和碳纳米管是碳原子的两种不同排列形式。这意味着你拥有最明亮的材料和最黑的材料，基本上是由同一种元素产生的。这种为斯特里布创造的新型碳纳米管材料实际上取代了梵塔黑，成为世界上新的最黑材料。它吸收了惊人的99.995%的光线，相比之下，梵塔黑为99.955%。这很讽刺，因为她开发出比阿尼什·卡普尔更黑的黑色的唯一原因就是阿尼什·卡普尔。如果不是因为与卡普尔的独家许可，麻省理工学院和斯特里布的新纪录保持者
Diamond and carbon nanotubes are two forms of carbon atoms in a different order. That means that you have the most brightest material, and the most blackest material, basically generated from the same element. This new carbon nanotube material created for stream actually unseeded Vanta Black as the new blackest material in the world. It traps an astronomical 99.995 percent of light as comparative Vanta Blacks 99.955 percent%. Which is ironic because the only reason she developed a blacker black than a niche Kapoor's is because of a niche Kapoor. Had it not been for the exclusive license with Kapoor, MIT and Strebes' new record-breaking
材料可能就不会存在。通过选择不与其他艺术家合作，Surrey NanoSystems无意中激发了一种超越他们纪录的竞争性超黑材料。但斯特里布说，她并不是想胜过Surrey NanoSystems或向阿尼什·卡普尔发表声明。她只是想超越争吵，创造艺术。我喜欢艺术是自由的，并通过其概念力量和美学说话。我并不感兴趣对阿尼什·卡普尔或任何人竖起道德的手指。
material might not exist by choosing not to work with other artists. Surinanos unintentionally inspired a rival super black material that beat their record. But Streep says she wasn't trying to one up Surrey Nanosystems or make a statement to Anish Kapoor. Everything she was just trying to move past the bickering and create art. I like art to be free and speak through its conceptual powers and aesthetics. I do not, I'm not interested in raising the moral fingertip to Anish Kapoor or anybody else.
阿尼什·卡普尔仍然拥有在艺术作品中使用梵塔黑的独家权利，目前尚不清楚他是否计划使用该材料发布任何未来的作品。实际上，他最近的展览与黑色相去甚远。这是一系列几乎无法反射的镜面雕塑。如今，斯图尔特·森普尔有了新的巨人要挑战。他盯上了T-Mobile。该公司一直在向使用与其商标粉色相似色调的小企业发送停止侵权通知。因此，为了抗议，他发布了一种他称之为“粉色TM”（Pink TM）的新颜料。它与T-Mobile的颜色完全匹配，任何人都可以使用，
Anish Kapoor still has the exclusive rights to use Vanta Black in his artwork, and it's unclear whether he's planning on releasing any future pieces using the material. Actually, his most recent exhibition couldn't be any further away from Black. It's a series of mirrored sculptures that are almost impossibly reflective. These days, Stewart Simple has a new giant to Sla. He's taken on T-Mobile. The company has been sending cease-and-assists to small businesses using a similar shade to their trademark pink. So in protest, he's released a new pigment that he calls pink TM. It's an exact color match to T-Mobile's and it's available to anyone,
除非他们以任何方式与T-Mobile有关联。本·詹森仍然在Surrey NanoSystems，开发梵塔黑的新迭代版本，这些版本不对任何艺术家独家提供。但他似乎有点犹豫是否要再次与艺术家合作。他似乎很满足于回到他童年时向太空发射超酷事物的卑微抱负。就我个人而言，我热爱太空事业。我绝对热爱它。就像我说的，我从小就试图制造太空火箭。今天，我们创造的材料正在绕地球运行。我无法告诉你这让我感觉如何。你知道，那个在黑夜里看着月亮，心想
unless they're in any way affiliated with T-Mobile. Ben Jensen is still at Serenano Systems, developing newer iterations of Vanta Black that are not exclusive to any artist. But he seemed a little hesitant to work with artists again. He seems pretty content to return to his humble childhood ambitions of blasting super-acor things into space. Personally, I love the space business. I just absolutely love it. Like I said, I started as a young kid trying to build space rockets. And today we have materials that we create orbiting the earth. And I cannot tell you how that makes me feel. You know, this little kid that was looking at the moon on dark nights and thought,
“我想把东西送到太空”的小男孩，今天，我们真的把东西送到了太空。至于麻省理工学院研发出的黑色，德穆特·斯特里布知道这不会是世界上最黑颜料的终点。另一种材料最终会出现并结束它们作为“最黑的黑色”的统治，但对斯特里布和Next Lab来说，重要的不是他们的材料是最黑的，而是它对艺术界的其他人开放。所以目前，最黑的黑色对任何艺术家开放使用，包括阿尼什·卡普尔。梵塔黑的对立面是什么？梵塔白（Vanta White）。
I want to send something up to space to today, we actually send stuff into space. As for the black that came out of MIT, D-Moodstreeb knows that this isn't going to be the end-all be-all for the world's darkest pigment. Another material will eventually come along and end their reign as the blackest black, but what's important to Striben Next Lab isn't that their material is the darkest, but that it's available to the rest of the art world. So for now, the blackest black is open to any artist to use, including Anishikapur. What's the opposite of Vant Black? Vant White.
实际上，那不是答案。但我们确实有一个关于一种颜色颜料的故事，它非常令人向往，以至于它成为了一起经济间谍案的中心。亚当·罗杰斯回来在休息后告诉我那个故事。梵塔黑故事的一个重要收获是，我们周围到处都是颜色，但我们并没有真正花太多心思去思考创造它的过程。记者亚当·罗杰斯，我们在梵塔黑故事中听过他的讲述，他正在写一本关于颜色的书，他来到演播室和我谈论了背后的技术。
Actually, that's not the answer. But we do have a story about a color pigment that is so desirable, it was at the center of a case of economic espionage. Adam Rogers comes back to tell me that story after the break. One of the big takeaways of the Vanta Black story is that there is color all around us, but we don't really put a lot of thought into the process of creating it. Journalist Adam Rogers, who we heard from in the Vantablack story, and who was writing a whole book about colors, came into the studio to talk to me about the technology behind
另一种颜料非常抢手，以至于它成为了一项联邦调查局调查的中心。你以前可能没听说过它，但耶稣啊，你可能一天都没有，甚至一小时都没有，不与它接触。它就是二氧化钛。关于二氧化钛最酷的事情是每个人一直在与它互动。是的。因为它是，主要是，它是
another pigment that was so sought after that it was at the center of an FBI investigation. You may not have heard of it before, but Jesus is, you haven't gone a day, maybe, haven't even gone an hour, without coming into contact with it. It is titanium dioxide. The coolest thing about titanium dioxide is that everyone interacts with it all the time. Yeah. Because it is, primarily, it's the thing
让几乎所有人类制造的东西变白的东西。白色，如果你明白我的意思。是的，是的。它会赋予事物一种近乎柏拉图式的白色原则。它还会传达不透明度和亮度。所以你在其他颜色、其他颜料中也能找到它，房屋油漆，它可能占40%。
that makes almost every human-made thing white. White, if you see what I mean. Yeah, yeah. It'll confer an almost platonic principle of whiteness to do things. It'll convey opacity and brightness as well. So you find it in other colors, other pigment, house paints, it'll be like 40%.
二氧化钛，无论它们是什么颜色，即使是红色的。但二氧化钛也存在于许多不同的颜色中，就像你买的管装钛白油画颜料一样，如果你买的是真货的话。有一个故事，它可能是伪造的，在冷战期间，西方比俄罗斯集团拥有更多的二氧化钛获取渠道，所以你应该能够看到，柏林墙后的东西看起来有点肮脏和
Titanium dioxide, no matter what color they are, even if they're red. But titanium dioxide's in a bunch of different colors, as well as being like in a tube of titanium white oil paint that you would buy if you get the real stuff There was a story that it may be apocryphal The during the Cold War the West had more access to titanium dioxide than Russia block affiliated so you were supposed to be able to see one of the reasons that the like behind the Berlin Wall things look kind of dingy and
昏暗，饱和度不高，原因之一是他们的油漆，随着时间的推移，会透出底色。他们没有那么多二氧化钛。他们没有使用二氧化钛，但西方使用了。所以当你走过勃兰登堡门时，西方会变得明亮而美丽，颜色更多，那是因为这个原因。这可能是伪造的，但我非常喜欢这个故事，它对我来说很受用。它甚至在食物里，对吧？是的，很多食物。特别是像奥利奥夹心之类的东西，我想他们不再使用它了。像救生圈糖果或纸杯蛋糕上的糖珠之类的东西。非常多。在那些药品中，
dim and not as saturated was that their paints, as they got old, they would show through more. They didn't have as much titanium dioxide. They weren't using titanium dioxide, but the west was. So when you would walk through the Brandenburg Gate and the west would be all bright and beautiful and there was more color, it was because of that. That may be apocryl, but I love the story so much that it works for me. And it's even in food, right? Yeah, a lot of food. Especially the things like Oreo filling, I think they don't use it anymore. Something like a like a life saver or like sprinkles on cupcakes. Very lot. It of titanium dioxide in those pharmaceuticals,
药丸，如果你药柜里有药丸，几乎每种药丸里都有很多，剃须膏肯定有，剃须膏是一个大头。瓷器，如果你在厨房和浴室里走动，很多表面和很多小物体都是，你会看到成分表上有TI-02。二氧化钛是如何被发现的？嗯，钛实际上被发现是一种非常常见的元素。
pills, like almost every pill if you have pills in your medicine cabinet, a lot of it in that, shaving cream for sure, shaving cream is a big one. Porcelains, the things that are in, if you walk around your kitchen in your bathroom, a lot of those surfaces and a lot of the small objects are, you will see TI-02 on that ingredient level. How is titanium dioxide discovered? Well, titanium was actually discovered that they element very common.
地壳中含量最高的元素，是在磨坊的引水渠中发现的，那是你从河流中切出侧渠流经磨坊的小溪，没人知道该拿它怎么办，没人知道它是干什么用的，但在19世纪末，一位名叫AJ·罗西（AJ Rossi）的工程师在玩弄它，因为他在试图从阿迪朗达克山脉的含铁矿石中制造钢铁时遇到了它。没人知道你是否可以用它来制造更好的钢。他创办了一家公司，认为他可以，为了做到这一点，他需要大量的电力来使熔炉足够热以完成这项工作。
Nights most common element in the Earth's crust discovered in a in the leat of a mill that's the little the stream that you sort of cut the side channel from a river to go through a mill nobody knew what to do with it nobody knew what it was for but in the late 1800s an engineer named AJ Rossi was playing with it because he had encountered it trying to make steel from the iron bearing ores of the Adirondacks. Nobody knew if you could use it to make that steel better. He started a company that thought he could, and to do it, he needed a lot of power to make the furnace as hot enough to make this work.
所以他去了19世纪末和20世纪初的“硅谷”，也就是尼亚加拉大瀑布。因为所有的电力。因为所有的电力。对。好的。所以是水力发电。对。
So he went to what was sort of the Silicon Valley of the late 1800s and early 1900s, which was Niagara Falls. Because of all the power. Because of all the power. Right. Okay. So the hydroelectric power. Right.
所以他在做电化学。哦，酷。这是联合碳化物公司（Union Carbide）开始的地方。如果你想做这种需要大量电力的奇怪的、炼金术般的、神奇的化学反应，你可以裂解矿物，裂解矿石，并以新的、奇怪的方式将它们混合在一起。所以尼亚加拉大瀑布有很多这样的公司开始运营。他的公司就是其中之一。但在过程中的某个时刻，该过程的副产品之一是二氧化钛会
So he was doing electrochemistry. Oh, cool. And this is the place where like union carbides started. If you wanted to do this weird, alchemical, magical chemistry that needed a lot of power, you could crack open minerals, crack open ores and mix them together in new, weird ways. So there were all these companies that started up in Niagara Falls. His was one of them. But at one point in the process, one of the byproducts of the process was titanium dioxide would
沉淀出来，成为这种美丽的亮白色粉末。罗西足够聪明，知道当时对某种东西的需求巨大，可以取代自古以来经典的增白剂、遮光剂和白色颜料——铅。人们发现了一些铅的缺点。是的。但他看到了这种白色。
precipitate out as this beautiful bright white powder. And Rossi was smart enough to know that there was a huge demand at that moment for something to replace. What was the classic, brightener, opacifier, and white pigment since antiquity, which was lead. There was some discover, the shortcomings of lead. Yes. But he sees this white.
沉淀为这种美丽的亮白色粉末。罗西很聪明，他知道当时市场对替代品有巨大的需求。自古以来，铅一直是经典的增亮剂、遮光剂和白色颜料。当时人们已经发现铅存在一些缺陷。是的，但他看到了这种白色物质。
He sees the white. And he goes, I know what this could do, potentially. And he mixes it with salad oil. Okay. And he runs his finger across it, puts his finger in it, runs it across a piece of paper. It's this beautiful white. And he says, aha, we. Okay. And he runs his finger across it, puts his finger in it, runs it across a piece of paper. It's this beautiful white and he says, aha, we got it. We got it.
他看到了白色，心想，我知道这东西潜在的用途。于是他把它和色拉油混合在一起。好了，他用手指蘸了一下，涂在纸上。那是种美丽的白色。他说，啊哈，我们成功了。我们成功了。
And he starts a company, gets sort of suspended by World War I, but once that's over, he's the only kind of town, then our region's come up with a process too. And now there's this way to make titanium dioxide, and it becomes ubiquitous in human industry. How big of an industry is titanium dioxide? It varies, but I think right now it's like a $4 billion a year industry and I forget the amounts. It's some hundreds of two T.E.U. cargo units a year.
他创办了一家公司，但被第一次世界大战中断了。战争结束后，他是镇上唯一一家，然后我们地区也想出了一种工艺。现在有了这种制造二氧化钛的方法，它在人类工业中变得无处不在。二氧化钛的产业规模有多大？虽然有所波动，但我认为目前它是一个每年40亿美元的产业，具体数量我记不清了，大约是每年几十万吨的货物量。
But that doesn't seem like a lot if you know, know how much cash Apple has on hand or something. But it's, it minutes a amount of it or in everything that we touch every day. Almost everything that we touch every day. And so to me that makes it one of those invisible pieces of things that we touch that makes the world look the way it does.
如果你知道苹果公司手头有多少现金，这看起来似乎不算多。但它无处不在，存在于我们每天接触的每一样东西中。几乎我们每天接触的每一样东西。所以对我来说，这使它成为我们接触到的那些无形事物之一，正是这些东西让世界呈现出现在的样子。
Since it was discovered there have been these various methods to make it. Tell me about that. The process that Rossi figured out, and the one that was in place really until kind of around, a little before World War II, it was called the sulfide process, it's really gross, it's really dirty, requires sulfuric acid, and it requires a fairly pure ore to turn into titanium dioxide, and it's not very efficient. So in the 30s, a chemist named Paul Kubelka figured out a way to use hydrochloric acid.
自从它被发现以来，就有各种各样的制造方法。跟我说说这个。罗西（Rossi）想出的工艺，以及在二战前一直沿用的工艺，被称为硫酸法。它非常粗糙，非常肮脏，需要硫酸，而且需要相当纯的矿石才能转化为二氧化钛，效率并不高。所以在30年代，一位名叫保罗·库贝尔卡（Paul Kubelka）的化学家想出了一种使用盐酸的方法。
So the chloride process was born, a complicated industrial process that uses really big factories that you know look like steam punk kind of star destroyers. They're fantastic. I got to miss it when they're amazing. He figures that out. That process becomes the de facto. You can use kind of dirtier ores, and it's more efficient. It's a better way to make the stuff. And through various waves of acquisitions and purchases,
于是氯化法诞生了，这是一种复杂的工业流程，使用看起来像蒸汽朋克风格的歼星舰那样巨大的工厂。它们太棒了，我错过了它们，它们令人惊叹。他想出了这个方法。这个工艺成为了事实上的标准。你可以使用更劣质的矿石，而且效率更高。这是制造这种材料的更好方法。通过几轮收购和购买，
this becomes the property of DuPont. So DuPont becomes the main purveyor of chloride process, titanium dioxide for the world, essentially, and that becomes sort of a de facto standard. So there's continual evolution of how to make better and cleaner titanium dioxide. And this eventually leads to a big intellectual property case. So tell me about that and how that got started. So in like the mid 2000s, DuPont goes to the FBI and says, listen, we're pretty sure somebody
这成为了杜邦公司的财产。因此，杜邦公司基本上成为了全球氯化法二氧化钛的主要供应商，这成为了事实上的标准。所以，如何制造更好、更清洁的二氧化钛一直在不断演进。这最终导致了一起重大的知识产权案件。跟我说说那件事以及它是如何开始的。大约在2000年代中期，杜邦公司找到联邦调查局（FBI）说，听着，我们很确定有人
has stolen our chloride process for making titanium dioxide. We're pretty sure we know who, we're pretty sure we know who he's selling it to. And the FBI, which has just started, not by coincidence, an economic espionage office in Silicon Valley, because Congress has just passed the first economic espionage act, essentially because they are worried about the same thing Dupont is, which is that China is trying to take IP from American companies. I see. China is trying to take IP from American companies. Nice see, okay. So DuPont goes to the FBI and says,
窃取了我们制造二氧化钛的氯化工艺。我们很确定知道是谁，也很确定知道他卖给了谁。而联邦调查局——并非巧合的是——刚刚在硅谷成立了一个经济间谍办公室，因为国会刚刚通过了第一部《经济间谍法》，本质上是因为他们担心和杜邦公司一样的事情，那就是中国正试图从美国公司窃取知识产权。我明白了。中国正试图从美国公司窃取知识产权。我明白了，好的。所以杜邦公司找到联邦调查局说，
we are pretty sure that this dude named Walter Liu is selling our chloride process for building factories for making or into titanium dioxide to the Chinese government. And how did Walter Liu get his hands on the DuPont method? Walter Liu, according to later trial documents, this foil that a little bit, so found his way to a state dinner in China,
我们很确定这个叫沃尔特·刘（Walter Liu）的人正在向中国政府出售我们建造二氧化钛工厂的氯化工艺。沃尔特·刘是怎么拿到杜邦公司的方法的？根据后来的审判文件，沃尔特·刘稍微伪造了一下，他在中国的一次国宴上找到了门路，
where he had kind of promised that he knew how to make stuff that was on a literal list that the Chinese government had said, gosh, we'd sure like it. If somebody could teach us how to do this stuff for Chinese industrial reasons. Okay. That'd be great. And they kind of showed him the list. And he was like, yeah, totally can make you guys titanium dioxide with his buddy sort of nudging go like, Walter, we don't know how to make titanium dioxide. It's like, it's fine. We're good. It's fine. And
在那里他承诺自己知道如何制造中国政府清单上明确列出的东西，他们说，天哪，如果有人能教我们如何制造这些东西用于中国工业，那真是太好了。好吧，那太棒了。他们把清单给他看。他说，是的，我完全可以为你们制造二氧化钛。他的伙伴还在旁边推搡他说，沃尔特，我们根本不知道怎么制造二氧化钛。他说，没关系，我们能行。没关系。然后
what Lou eventually ended up doing with the FBI eventually understood, Lou to end up doing was finding a couple of, this is more disrespectful than I mean to say, but essentially finding a couple of disgruntled X-Dupont employees, engineers who had helped develop and deploy the chloride process factories that DuPont could build in the US and other countries,
刘最终所做的事情，联邦调查局最终了解到的，是找到了一些——这比我想表达的更不尊重，但本质上是找到了一些心怀不满的前杜邦员工，那些曾帮助开发和部署杜邦在美国和其他国家建造的氯化法工厂的工程师，
who had left the company unhappy and with their boxes of stuff. deploy the chloride process factories that DuPont could build in the US and in other countries, who had left the company unhappy and with their boxes of stuff. And with those, he kind of lose started in the mission. It's just go start at a little storefront office where he like processed that information and sold it to the Chinese. How does DuPont figure this out? And then how does the FBI start to stitch together the case? DuPont was cagey with how they figured it out.
他们带着一箱箱资料离开了公司，心怀不满。有了这些，刘就开始了他的使命。他只是在一个小店面办公室里开始，处理这些信息并将其卖给中国人。杜邦公司是怎么发现的？然后联邦调查局是如何开始拼凑这个案件的？杜邦公司对他们是如何发现的守口如瓶。
Even with the FBI, or the FBI was cagey with me about how DuPont had told them, they figured DuPont has its own internal security. They're very worried about this kind of stuff. But they found out somehow, and they said to the FBI, we think it's this guy. The FBI started surveillance and looked into both the people who Lou was working with on the East Coast and Delaware, his office here, and eventually got enough evidence to say we are pretty sure that he's the guy. And we're pretty sure that he's about to have a meeting with his Chinese contacts
即使是对联邦调查局，或者联邦调查局对我关于杜邦如何告诉他们这件事也守口如瓶。他们认为杜邦有自己的内部安全部门。他们非常担心这类事情。但他们不知怎么发现了，并告诉联邦调查局，我们认为是这个人。联邦调查局开始监视，并调查了刘在东海岸和特拉华州合作的人，以及他在那里的办公室，最终获得了足够的证据说，我们很确定他就是那个人。而且我们很确定他即将与他的中国联系人会面。
Well, I'm a given day. Okay, and we're pretty sure that they're staying in a crummy hotel in Alameda And they in conjunction with a relatively new US attorney in San Francisco who really wanted to get some action out of this office Figured out how to mount a bi-coastal, multi-place exercise search warrants on everybody all at once, hundreds of agents deployed. And I mean, so this is a huge, is this the first case that's sort of executed in the S.P. knowledge act? It was the first case prosecutor under the economic S.P. knowledge act. And then, so was the first, it was the first guy's prosecutor and under the economic Espionage Act. Yeah. And then so what is, what ended up, what was the result?
在某一天。好的，我们很确定他们住在阿拉米达的一家破旧酒店里。他们与旧金山一位相对较新的联邦检察官合作，该检察官非常希望在办公室里有所作为，他们想出了如何进行一次跨海岸、多地点的行动，同时对所有人执行搜查令，数百名特工出动。我的意思是，这是一起巨大的案件，这是《经济间谍法》下执行的第一起案件吗？这是根据《经济间谍法》起诉的第一起案件。那么，结果如何？
What's he convicted? He was convicted and is still in prison. They never found the money. The money that the Chinese government turned out, had paid Walter and his family. And China has an active core ed process, titanium dioxide processing business out, because they had this kind of crummy
他被定罪了吗？他被定罪了，现在仍在监狱里。他们从未找到那笔钱。中国政府支付给沃尔特和他家人的钱。中国现在拥有了一个活跃的氯化法二氧化钛加工业务，因为他们之前有这种糟糕的矿石，却不知道如何将其转化为二氧化钛。现在他们知道了。是因为沃尔特·刘吗？也许吧，也许吧。或者也许他们自己在路上摸索出来了。也许吧。是的，为了颜料，为了颜色。为了能够制造一种颜色。
or grumpy or or and no way to make it into titanium dioxide. And now they do. Because of Walter Lou. Perhaps, perhaps. Or maybe they figured it out on the road. Maybe. And yes, for a pigment, for a color. To be able to make a color.
我非常喜欢“Vantablack”故事和这个故事的整个前提，我喜欢的是将颜色视为技术的理念。我认为这对人们来说是一个非常奇怪的概念。我也觉得这很奇怪，但让我补充一点。它一直都是技术。当然。生物对彩色世界有一种体验，一个充满色彩的世界，因为许多活着的生物
And I just love the whole premise of both of Antoblack story and this story, what I love about it is the idea of color as technology. Like that is a very, I think that's a strange notion to people. I think it's a strange notion too, but let me, let me yes and you. It's always been technology. Sure. There's this, there's the experience that a living thing will have of a colored world, a world of color, because a lot of the things that are alive on the
在地球上，它们与电磁波谱的物理特性相互作用的方式，包括我们称之为可见光的那一部分，因为对我们来说那是可见的部分。但在人类历史的某个时刻，我们可能取用了铁矿石，可能是赭石，对吧？把这块石头捣碎，混合一些动物脊骨里的脂肪，涂在洞穴墙壁上，或者涂在我们制造的东西上，不仅仅是为了防蚊子——这可能是它的一个作用，也不仅仅是为了粘合斧头——这可能是赭石浆的另一个作用，而是为了设计出某种东西来唤起某种情感。对吧。可能是红色，尽管也可能是黑色，
planet have ways of interacting with the physics of the electromagnetic spectrum that include the part of it that we call visible because for us it's the visible part. But there's a moment in human history where we take probably iron ore, it's probably ochre, right? Take this rock, crunch it up, mix it with trebecular fat from some animals back bone and smear it on a k-wall or smear it on a thing that we make, not just to protect it against mosquitoes, which is possibly a thing that it does, not just to glue together the half-defin axe, which is another thing that maybe Yoker, you know, pulp does, to make a design to evoke something. Right. Probably red, although it might have been black,
也可能是白色。白色是不太持久的颜色，所以很难知道。在那一刻，我们与彩色宇宙的互动也成为了一种技术，它成为了一种技术互动。《99% Invisible》本周由Vivian Le制作。由Sherefusif进行混音和技术制作，音乐由Sean Riel创作。Katie Mingle是我们的高级制作人，Kurt Colestad是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Emmet Fitzgerald，
and it might have been white. White's the thing that doesn't last as long as others are so hard to know. And at that moment, like, our interaction with the colored universe becomes a one-up technique as well, it becomes a technological interaction. 99% of visible was produced this week by Vivian Le. Mixed in tech production by Sherefusif, music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colestad, is the first to be released this week by Vivian Le. Mix and Tech Production by Srivthusif, Mutak by Sean Riyal. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team is Emmet Fitzgerald,
Avery Trollman, Joe Rosenberg, Delaney Hall, Chris Barube, Sophia Klatsker，还有我Roman Mars。特别感谢Adam Rogers，当他的书《About Color》出版时，我们会在屋顶上大声宣传。在此期间，你可以在《连线》（Wired）杂志上阅读他关于科学和各种极客知识的文章。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的市中心Radio Row制作，
Avery Trollman, Joe Rosenberg, Delaney Hall, Chris Barube, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Adam Rogers when his book, About Color Comes Out, we will shout it from the rooftops. In the meantime, you can read his stories about science and miscellaneous geekery at Wired. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown,
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。《99% Invisible》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm上可以找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@Roman Mars，关注节目@99PI org。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。如果你想看人们第一次看到Vantablack时惊呆的视频，
Oakland, California. 99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radtopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. If you want to see a video of people freaking out when they see Vandablaq for the first
你应该去99pi.org。非常感谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
time, you should go to 99ipi.org. Thank you very much. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。